[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i'm going
to explain a tamil language science
fiction action film called 2.0
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
eight years ago a highly advanced ai
robot named chidi wreaked havoc in
chennai india its creator dr vasigaran
helped dismantle it and send it to a
museum at present time he is working on
a similar project but with precautions
to avoid making the mistakes that he
made with chitty until now he has been
able to create an android named nila
unlike chitty she is not equipped with
military weapons and has manageable
human emotions she is a perfect
household and work assistant one day a
group of college students arrives at dr
vasegaran's lab to study his humanoid
robots when asked about the robot chitty
the doctor claims that he might be
revived if his services are needed in
the future but for now he is better off
at the museum after the session a
student is on his cell phone when
suddenly a strange force pulls it out of
his hands stunned the guy reaches for it
in midair but the phone refuses to move
a video of a bird plays on it before it
flies away and disappears into the sky
following the incident several similar
cases occur throughout the city of
chennai from street vendors to mobile
shops not a single cell phone is left in
the city by the end of an hour the
police station is swarmed by commoners
reporting they're missing phones but the
cops are just as clueless as everyone
else soon a scientific council led by
minister kumar gathers to discuss the
phenomenon some believe that the cause
of the phenomenon is either a terrorist
attack an alien invasion or global
warming but vesigrand debunks all the
theories and explains that the phones
have not crossed chennai's border and
have not reached the troposphere this
means they are somewhere near the
outskirts of the city a phone company
owner confirms that all the phones are
switched off at once making it
impossible for anyone to track them it
is almost as if they have gained
consciousness and are behaving as a hive
in the following scene a vehicle full of
the latest batch of mobile phones
crashes on its way to the dealer
hundreds of phones from inside of it fly
away like the rest of them then we are
introduced to a mobile phone store owner
jf he is driving home in his car which
is being followed by an enormous swarm
of phones at midnight he is woken up by
vibration when he opens his eyes he is
shocked to see that his room is covered
in phones so much so that he cannot find
the door to run outside the swarm
displays birds on its screens before
entering his body causing him to explode
and die the following morning police are
confused by the nature of his death
since there are no signs of struggle
while investigating nila and visegaran
find electronic parts of mobile phones
scattered around the room visigoran sets
up a tracker and a phone and switches it
on to bait it towards the rest of the
storm the plan works and they locate the
area where the phones went after
disappearing visigoran and nila follow
the track and reach a small village as
they look for the electromagnetic signal
they are led to a river over which a
massive bird's talon has manifested
hundreds of thousands of phones are in a
swarm flying overhead showcasing a
phenomenon that is unheard of the talon
attacks a signal tower and breaks it
nila saves vasigaran from being killed
under the tower before the swarm departs
at the second council meeting vesigran
recommends reactivating his first robot
chitty to battle the new threat however
one of the council members bora is
strictly against the idea because of the
destruction chitty caused eight years
ago the minister vetoes the idea and
decides to use military protection
instead of reviving the robot bora is
clearly not on good terms with vasigaran
and blames him for his father's death
who was killed by chidi a long time ago
they get into a slight altercation after
the meeting telecom company owner lula
is furious at the situation that is
causing him a huge loss after urging
telecom minister morphy to solve the
problem quickly he drives back home but
on his way lula is attacked by the swarm
he stops the car only to see that the
entire highway is covered in phones the
swarm chases him into the forest and
eventually crushes him to death
following that it takes the shape of a
giant bird and flies away
the next day the telecom minister morthy
is paranoid since everyone associated
with him is being killed like the mobile
shop and telecom company owners suddenly
his phone which had disappeared like the
rest breaks into the house and starts
vibrating when they try to pick it up it
inserts itself into his body he is
immediately admitted into the hospital
where the minister visits him the
doctors along with the minister are
shocked to see the ultrasound results
that confirm that he has a cell phone
inside his body all of a sudden the
phone ruptures through his stomach and
kills him the minister finally
understands the severity of the
situation and calls vasigran to rebuild
chitty the doctor immediately works to
upgrade his old friend with new powers
and abilities the following day the cell
phone bird wreaks havoc on the city
destroying all the infrastructure that
comes in its way while simultaneously
dodging the military's defense it picks
a bunch of people up with its claws and
drops them from a height when the
civilians are left with no hope chitty
is revived stronger than ever he saves
the people mid-air and works to chase
the bird away the swarm drowns him in
the phones and creates a ball around him
but shitty manages to escape the trap
easily after jumping off a few
skyscrapers roller skating down the
highway and hijacking an armored truck
he manages to attract the bird away from
the crowd when the bird eats the truck
he triggers an explosion and destroys it
from the ruins the surviving phones
reform into a smaller bird and proceed
to attack chitty again this time he is
low on battery so he crawls to the space
station's generator and recharges the
bird retreats after being unable to
enter through the satellite antenna
after everything calms down shitty shows
vesigran the data he collected while
fighting the bird they deduce the bird
is a collective mass of negatively
charged electrons since a deceased being
is negatively charged they have all the
reasons to believe that a strange
phenomenon caused someone dead to gain
enough power to control the cell phones
in simpler words a negatively charged
soul is the one behind all of this after
finding out the cause dr vasigaran
invents a photon synthesizer that emits
positive signals at the target they hope
it will contain the creature and
neutralize its negative field visigran
also analyzes the clip of the bird
repeatedly and makes out a human face on
the bird's body he deduces that the face
must belong to the deceased who is
controlling the phones nyla digs through
some records on unusual cell phone
related deaths that occurred recently
they soon discover that a day before the
phone started flying a man committed the
unthinkable at a cell tower dr vesigaran
chidi and nyla drive the synthesizer to
the village where the phones supposedly
rest they encounter the swarm and are
immediately attacked the synthesizer
neutralizes it as it is supposed to but
the bird is stronger than they had
predicted chitty guards the machine with
his life eventually leading to the
majority of the aura being contained in
the device when the bird is almost
destroyed it manifests an egg that
transforms into a humanoid figure who is
also the soul they were looking for dr
vasigaran recognizes him as the deceased
ornithologist pakshi when shitty
inquires what his motive is pakshi calms
down and takes him to the ruins of a
house a flashback shows that the house
once used to be his home and a sanctuary
with hundreds of birds pakshi was
actually stillborn and the doctors had
given up on him but when he was lying on
his deathbed a sparrow flew to him and
revived him even years after the miracle
he passionately studied birds and
developed a connection with them but
recently the population of birds in
india has been declining on researching
the cause pakshi recognized that
radiation from mobile devices is messing
with birds nervous systems and their
ability to think eventually driving many
to insanity and irreversible sickness he
held many seminars and protests to make
people aware of the problem but no one
shared even an ounce of his sympathy for
the birds he was even mocked and taunted
for his apparently idiotic concern the
official who had the power to help him
was the telecom company owner lula
however when pakshi went to him with the
problem he was kicked out for wasting
his time still he did not give up he
protested outside cell phone stores but
was dragged away by the owners after all
he was a single man trying to fight with
a powerful group of people for animal
rights something they couldn't care less
about over time all the birds in his
sanctuary and in the wild suffered
depression and died while struggling a
heartbroken pakshi buried them all and
cried for days mourning the deaths of
his birds like children as the last
resort he arranged a meeting with the
telecom minister morthy and accused him
of all the deaths morthy retaliated
stating that they follow the law to
uphold their business but pakshi
realized that the telecom companies have
increased radiation standards illegally
to accelerate their business he sued the
companies in court and was successful to
some extent that is until the companies
turned their radiation down before
inspection and won the case pakshi had
no hope left for the betterment of the
lives of animals that he loved so dearly
soon the sadness turned into anger and
the anger into the will to take revenge
he didn't just want to avenge the
officials but also the irresponsible
civilians who kill avian life for their
own pleasure then one day he climbed the
tower that killed his birds and
committed the unthinkable but the
radiation emitted from the towers woke
his spirit up it also absorbed the souls
of all the deceased birds in the city
and created a massive ball of vengeful
energy whose only mission was to kill
back in the present chitty sympathizes
with pakshi and the pain he was put
through still pakshi is adamant about
killing everyone who uses phones because
there is no other way to end their
obsession unfortunately pakshi is
probably right about this somewhere else
vesigran uses the synthesizer to
restrict the creature however it only
makes him more aggressive chitty is
gravely hurt while trying to fight him
but is repaired by nila after being
revived he attacks pakshi and
neutralizes the negatively charged ions
trapping his soul in the neutralization
device a convention is held to
officially thank the trio for their
bravery the minister allows dr vasigaran
to create an army of 500 chitis which
will be donated to the military to
protect the nation visigoran is
overjoyed because his decades-long wish
to help the indian military is finally
being fulfilled however among the crowd
is his rival borah who is envious of his
accomplishments that night he breaks
into the lab and releases pakshi's
spirit from the stabilizer to get back
at vizigaran in no time pachi regains
control of the phones around the city
and becomes just as powerful as before
he possesses vesigran's body as a way to
threaten chitty from getting in his way
the villain then turns into his human
form and starts killing everyone who
comes in his way shitty tries to fight
him but has to stop when his attacks
hurt vasigaran
pakshi gains full control over the
situation and dismembers the robot nyla
realizes that chitty's emotional
attachment to the doctor is refraining
him from functioning properly in a time
of crisis the only robot who can stop
pakshi is chitty's evil alter ego chitty
2.0 he was the one who caused problems
and killed all those people eight years
ago although it is risky nylah decides
to revive him meanwhile pakshi enters a
stadium and imprisons 80 000 people
inside of it he takes away all of their
phones and multiplies in power bora who
is also at the stadium is his first
target even though he is on his side
before he can do more harm chitty 2.0
breaks into the stadium and summons his
army the one that the minister permitted
to have created pakshi collects all the
mobile phones again and transforms into
a massive humanoid while chidi does the
same using metal objects they battle
furiously but chitty is soon de-powered
pakshi is about to kill him when a
microbot of chitti's creation named cudi
interrupts him he alongside hundreds of
other cuddies mount on top of real doves
and threaten to hurt them if pakshi
doesn't back down even when dead
pakshi's love for the birds has not
lessened knowing that he cannot let any
more birds be harmed he backs down using
the opportunity the cuddies
self-destruct
and destroy pakshi's army of bird drones
at last chitty shoots dr vasigaran
causing pakshi to leave his body the
cudibots trap him in the signal streams
where chitty neutralizes him with a
positive charge and destroys him a few
weeks later visiguran is recovering in
the hospital he explains to a visiting
minister that pakshi's violence was
unjustifiable but his intentions were
not evil if they prioritize technology
over nature both will turn on humans as
pakshi did the minister orders an issue
to protect the remains of the bird
population in chennai in the ending
scene we see a budding relationship
between shitty and nyla subscribe for
more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching